move on to the french connection we are
learning new details of how the french
officials who designed and built
the now infamous wuhan lab in china were
abruptly removed
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin has the latest tonight from the
pentagon
u.s and french officials sounded alarm
bells about security at the wuhan
institute of virology as early as 2009
according to state department cables
it's a critical piece of data
that clearly that the cables indicate
the chinese had lacked security
standards
the press reporting on this also
indicates that the french have had a
very troubled relationship with the
chinese going back almost a decade
there were concerns tom denano a trump
appointee
was on the state department team
investigating the origin of covet 19
and tells fox that those concerns
centered on safety at the wuhan
institute of virology
and the wisdom of collaborating with the
chinese on such sensitive
biotechnology and research in 2004 the
french government
signed an agreement to help the chinese
build its first biosafety level 4 lab in
wuhan
to study infectious diseases in the wake
of the sars outbreak
despite the protests of french defense
officials the french were responsible
for managing the lab
safety protocols until they were
abruptly kicked out of the lab
by the chinese government in 2017
shortly after it was inaugurated
two years earlier french intelligence
warned the u.s government
that it had concerns about chinese
behavior at the lab
if it gets out of a lab that according
to david asher
the state department's former lead
investigator into the coveted origin
quote dgse francis cia were pretty
public in sounding their alarm bells
not typical i can't understand how nih
dod
and aid would continue to plow dollars
and transfer tech to wiv
in the wake of the french being
evacuated the signals will clear
uh we know the chinese have had a
offensive biological weapons program for
decades since they joined the biological
weapons
treaty in the 80s the french knew that
as well
tonight we are learning that secretary
of state blinken met with the who chief
today and affirmed u.s support for a new
w.h.o study into the origins of covet
19.
a proposal china has already rejected
outright
trace jen i know you've covered this
story extensively what can you tell us
tonight about the status of the afghan
combat translators
seeking to emigrate to the u.s well
trey's fox news has learned the first
plane of afghan combat
translators and their families about 250
in total
all of them recipients of what are known
as special immigrant visas
will land in the united states late
tomorrow early friday
and will be sent by bus to fort lee and
virginia about 2500 have been cleared so
far to come to the u.s
or to american military bases in the
middle east as they await
processing the plane is being organized
by the state department trace
that is a bit of good news jennifer
griffin live for us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else